how you doin youtube i'm dave rubin this
is the rubin report we have kim torture
from nerd alert and erie smyer from
dweeb cast this might be I'm willing to
make the prediction right now the
geektastic episode the biggest geek tack
geektastic the biggest give me another
nerd word dweeby well we got dweeb a
nerd one more geek geek nerd dweeb bro
bro this is gonna be the bro eous chick
show ever okay oh no Bros introspective
this is gonna be an introspective bro
chick geek show here we go alright
Dianne Feinstein Senator Dianne
Feinstein she is upset that the CIA
might be spying on the Senate ironic
because she might have been the one to
get us in this mess in the first place
she took it to the Senate floor let's
take a look questions related to who had
authorized and conducted the search and
what legal basis the CIA claimed gave it
authority to conduct the search again
the CIA has not provided answers to any
of my questions my letter also laid out
my concern about the legal and
constitutional implications of the CIA's
actions based on what director Brennan
has informed us I have grave concerns
that the CIA search may well have
violated the separation of powers
principles embodied in the United States
Constitution including the Speech and
Debate clause it may have undermined the
constitutional framework essential to
effective congressional oversight of
intelligence activities or any other
government function okay so that's
pretty serious stuff if the Senate is
spying on the CIA of course she didn't
have a problem when the Senate was
spying on us she voted for most of that
stuff if not all of it CIA director John
Brennan responded to miss Feinstein the
the matter is being dealt with in the
appropriate way the
looked at by the right authorities and
the facts will come out but let me
assure you that CIA in no way was spying
on the SSCI or the Senate we greatly
respect the separation of powers between
the executive branch and legislative
branch now I don't see why we'd have any
reason to think that someone in power at
the CIA or the NSA might be lying unless
it's happened before what I wanted to
see is if you could give me a yes or no
answer to the question does the NSA
collect any type of data at all on
millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans no sir it does not not
wittingly there are cases where they
could inadvertently perhaps collect but
not not wittingly and by not wittingly
of course we now know he means yes we
did and we do okay so first question
pretty simple out of the gate can we
trust any of these people forget
Feinstein for a second can we trust any
of them when they say what they're doing
or what they're not doing we clearly
have a president showing that no we
can't but one thing I'm kind of in the
midst of all this awful lying and going
back and forth between branches of
government this is a fight between two
different branches of government we
would have never seen in the pre Snowden
days so I'm glad that at least she
publicly said hey this isn't there
spying on us they're not supposed to be
doing that yeah so let's get to the
separation of powers in a second do you
think we can trust any of these people
we have clapper knowingly lied nothing's
happened to him he's still in all the
big meetings he has not been certainly
not I mean I think a reasonable
expectation of privacy is unreasonable
now I think it's a kind of come out now
now that we have technology I think
we're more maybe we're more or more it's
more visible that we can see that this
is actually happening where we're using
these leaks whereas in the past you know
hey maybe they were spying on us too yo
I just think that maybe now or more
aware of it yeah so the separation of
powers you brought up i think is the
interesting part is because nobody talks
about how the government's supposed to
work anymore but we have three branches
of government that you learn in politics
101 and they're supposed to keep each
other in check that's the whole point
but when she says that they do
regular people hear that and realize
what a sort of usurp enough power is
really going on well I think previously
they would have worked in tandem or or
kept this quiet and we're all supposed
to just trust our government and know
that they have what's best for us in
mind and you know when they say spy on
us and breach our security and civil
rights it's okay cuz it's for the
greater good but maybe not now huh yeah
you think you think maybe not what do
you make of the separation of powers
part is alright we just dumb down our
society part to the point where would
people say things like that but I don't
think it really breaks through the ether
sort of and why it's important to talk
about you got to think about our culture
in terms of what we do every single day
right we're on Facebook we're on twitter
we're stalking each other we're spying
on each other's private lives and stuff
like that I think the idea that the
government is doing it also it should a
not be a surprise what do they have like
probably Facebook plus or something pick
the pace the page version right where
they can let go and you know dig on you
and figure out what's going on but I
think that a people just are not that
phase by it they expect to be stocked
they expect to be followed and you know
when you have a president right who says
I don't need Congress to do anything I
can just take a pen and you know right
write a bill and I gotta buy that oh
that's right you can just do whatever he
wants and you know i'm not you know it
doesn't surprise me shouldn't surprise
any of us yeah so is the really scary
part here that if the CIA is spying on
Congress so spying on another branch of
government what what makes us think
they're not spying on Obama too because
I mean people are starting to talk about
that we have no reason to think if they
went ahead and figured out some legal
justification to spy on Congress and the
Senate why not the executive branch to
what makes you think Obama isn't isn't
in on it persuaded to what that equally
scary oh absolutely well I mean you know
since Obama resigned and Frank Underwood
is now president I think that it's
pretty clear that you know we like we
shouldn't you know not expect these kind
of things to happen for sure but uh you
know it it's a whole culture of of
Washington of like we're gonna be real
nice and we're gonna tell you all these
like pretty things to your face but then
we are going to go you know in the back
room and then check out your biometrics
and figure out exactly where you are and
what you're doing and how you're going
to vote so we can then better market
to you to figure out you know how we can
stay in back yeah I'm glad you mentioned
house of cards actually because it seems
to me that with all this NSA stuff going
on there's so little trust in government
and then at the same time house of cards
come out and of course it's a fictitious
show but everyone keeps saying oh it's
ninety percent real that's what all the
pundits say that's what all the actors
say so it's sort of like we just have no
clue what's going on should we just give
up having any real insight into how this
operates and how many people they have
to kill and drugs they have to do and
marriages they have to ruin get it to
make it happen we gotta try we can do
the best we can you we do the best we
can with what we have with the
information we have the information we
have was probably not so good and
probably hidden from us but I do like I
did appreciate the transparencies on at
least one side here yeah is this
incredibly disingenuous of Feinstein who
had no problem voting obviously for the
patriotic but plenty of other I mean she
knew about the domestic spying and
suddenly it's about her and her
computers and her investigation and now
I have some righteous indignation right
well a what does she have to hide what
you have hide miss feinstein like what's
going on over there you you know not
actually doing any congressional work or
you just like on etsy all day you know i
don't know and she simply selling
brother for sure it seems like she would
she would be a kind of person who does
that but uh you know look like no I've
now I've never been a big fan you know
quite honestly i think that i think that
uh you know when you look at her her
voting record as far as you know heard
her hypocritical kind of stance now is
really pretty obvious yeah and then
that's what a lot of people are talking
about so final thought on this is this
the type of thing because it's about the
senate and if they know one thing it's
self-preservation is this the type of
thing that maybe will push back against
the NSA a little bit more because they
don't really care when it's happening to
us but when it's happening to them maybe
this thing will get it to critical mass
and then you'll have people like Rand
Paul who's been hugely against it so
it's sort of going on both sides of the
aisle so maybe some goodness here I do
like well before sometimes people had
said oh well you're crazy if you think
they're spying on you don't be paranoid
don't be delusional it's not paranoid
delusion especially if we have a known
hypocrite in public office telling us
this is happening yeah I hypocrite in
public office can you blow this turkey
yeah
ever never heard of that shocking I I
think that you know from a public
standpoint it's up to us to actually
care about you know and if we start
banging the drum we say like hey we're
not going to stand for this this is
ridiculous then then we'll get sort of
you know maybe some some good stuff
happening there all right let's keep go
let's talk about the devices with which
they use to spy on us there is a new
iphone coming if you go to yahoo com
every day there's 18 stories before they
get to anything else about the new
iphone 6 and a designer named Sam
Beckett has come up with a mock-up of
what he thinks the iphone 6 is going to
look like and he's using a lot of
contextual clues from things that are
leaking out of China and things like
that and we've got a little video for
you oh my god have you ever seen
anything sexier in your life and that
music I mean the guy should work for
Apple and make commercials because that
was pretty good actually some of the
things that they're saying that the
iphone 6 is going to have a larger 4.7
inch display which is up from four
inches point seven inches that's a
pretty good resolution of 1920 x 1080
which is sixty-eight percent more pixels
and it's going to be nine percent
thinner of course this is not confirmed
this is just what they're saying all
right so we talked a lot about the apple
stuff here are you guys both iphone or
an iphone err i do but i'm probably
going to jump ship next time alright
let's we'll get to that in a moment why
you're gonna do it am some guy you're a
samsung guy you're fighting the power in
a way my own in my own sort of way I rip
my carrier originally didn't carry the
iphone so like by default I was fighting
the power and now I just kind of you
know fallen in line like that what
carrier were you I was at with t-mobile
it's t-mobile now you can do it but
you'd have done right i would have to
you know and it was this big thing and i
like here's the thing the number one
thing about the iphone what i really
can't handle is that it doesn't matter
if the screen is bigger than the matter
if there's more pixels and it's thinner
like i need something that's not
shatter when I like knock it off my
Knights hand in the middle of like a
night terror you know I need something
like fall out of my pocket at crazy
girls on the Sunset Strip and not be
broken into a million pieces and so for
that reason alone I really like the
plastic displays of the Samsung I did
not know you suffer from night terror
good luck with that it's a real crazy
Earl said Chris a crazy girl well
supposedly the glass on this new one is
going to be some super strong thing that
you literally were able to like throw it
on the ground and will not affect it why
are you considering jumping ship I
really um the camera I don't think it's
the best quality camera I get that weird
white fuzz when I take darker pictures I
just want a better camera so this is all
about camera for me do you guys think
that with this technology that sometimes
you're actually in too deep to ever get
out because that's sort of how that's
sort of how I feel with the iphone 6 I
feel like it's the Mafia like it's easy
to get in but it's hard to get out like
everything I have I have a macbook I
have an ipad i have an iphone it's like
I get how would I even do it it would be
scary to me to be like no no I'm moving
to not be a fanboy but it's not even
fanboys literally like it's not about
the fanboy part it's literally the part
where it's well how am I going to now
sink this thing with my old pictures and
all that kind of stuff can we take some
work invitation I have to bring in a
professional maybe even a genius may be
a genius but do you think do you think a
lot of people feel that cuz there is
this growing don't you feel this growing
resentment of Apple they've become the
model if that they used to rail against
in that famous 1984 commercial and
that's what they become right without a
doubt I mean I think that after you saw
the Steve Jobs movie kind of could never
really buy another Apple product in good
faith and I and I also think that music
has a movie sucked because it was a bad
story was a great story love Steve Jobs
yeah but uh you know I i started waning
myself off of apple products about two
years ago because i was like you know
what i was spending so much money on
these things and they you know they're
really just not very robust so i
switched over to a pc for editing you
know for our show we use all pcs and
it's a lot cheaper there a lot easier to
sort of like finagle and mess with and i
think for for bang for buck you know
it's like you're you're kind of like
that that hipster guy who's hanging on
you know to the fixed gear bicycle if
you're if you're still like super apple
fan
boy no these days you said pc and
finagle in the same sentence that might
be the nerdiest thing that's ever been
said that's not thats not even like like
like comic book nerd which is like a
different level of social anxiety yeah
how much of this does go to the Steve
Jobs thing that because he's not there
it seems like they're not innovating
anymore that's what everyone's saying
that even these little specks okay some
more pixels a slightly nicer camera a
little thinner but they're not
reinventing themselves and they haven't
since he's been since he's been gone
well Tim Cook has done a pretty good job
but you know it's a little thinner it's
really that the innovator that Steve
Jobs was I yes the specs are just
improving slightly each time the 5s too
many people was a disappointment yeah we
wanted something more maybe something
bigger maybe different vastly different
specs and it's just a slight upgrade
each time and the 5c was a huge flop
actually and they're partly saying
that's because it was cheaper and Apple
people want to spend more money would
you want it to be a luxury item yeah is
that it would you not buy something
because it was cheaper with that team no
i mean i bought the samsung phone
because it was so much cheaper and yeah
for me it's like it's a phone you know
it's like I need any Google Docs and
that's how you can get away from the
cloud issue and syncing and everything
like that you just have something that's
surprising you just have to trust Google
because there are you watching yeah oh
right because Google not a problem Apple
problem actually I was driving on Santa
Monica yesterday and I was being
followed by a Google car I'm not kidding
I mean I think it's really following me
but I mean it was behind me that that's
scary that they're just googles just
driving around with cameras filming the
whole damn thing right here we are and
also building robots but bought an evil
robot factory Boston Dynamics so you
know it's not like that a couple things
could ever get together and cause any
trouble for anybody they think that'll
be a problem they're gonna have robots
on the streets and drones and yeah
google has bought up not only Boston
Dynamics but at least six major robotics
firms and it makes people wonder what
are they going to do next with what is
their next plan because they've started
to get into hardware didn't go so well
robots are the epitome of hardware
especially what you know Boston Dynamics
makes very lifelike strong fast robots
right so when someone comes knocking on
your door asking for
John Connor you'll know there's a
problem you give you give them John
Connor all right final thought I listen
every time we've done an apple thing
I've asked this question does do they
end up losing their mojo in the next
year or two because of this sort of
building thing of a not bringing us
products that are revolutionary again
because it's been a couple years as I
just said and then be just this general
feeling of like you're so cool you're
not cool anymore a general feeling I
feel as liz has really proliferated like
we see these Samsung commercials with a
bunch of dumb hipster standing in line
like sheep and not really thinking on
their own and then that kind of general
malaise just kind of takes over even if
the products themselves they're not bad
products they're good products right the
mentality is getting stronger and
stronger yeah as a style icon is a
status symbol I think Apple you know
obviously just like any other trend
first it was Tommy Hilfiger and then it
was you know not and then it was back to
tommy hilfiger and I think that things
just you know I've been flow what Apple
has done though over their history you
know they had some rough times people
counted out apples so many times I think
they're in a much better position you
know as far as market cap and and
viability to continue to make really
good products and if they are going to
continue to make good products and
they'll be fine yeah and by the way for
those of you that think Apple might
actually be in trouble you know during
the oscars Ellen did the the selfie
heard round the world three million plus
retweets that was on a samsung phone
which obviously was paid for for her do
but backstage she was tweeting on her
iPhone so there you go ok so I wanted to
talk about violence in video games
because I've got to pro gamers with me
I've confirmed that independently these
are big video game people you guys may
remember that I was assistant manager
Electronics Boutique in Hicksville Long
Island in the late 90s so I know a
little bit about topic myself moved more
Pokemon than anyone that's that's what I
tell people the American Psychological
Association on their website lists some
myths vs. facts about video game
violence and I'm not quite sure I agree
with them myth number one violent video
game research has yielded very mixed
results facts this is according to them
some studies have yielded non sig
nificant video game effects just as some
smoking studies failed to find a
significant link to lung cancer violent
video games are significantly associated
with increased aggressive behavior
thoughts and effect increased
physiological arousal and decreased
pro-social helping behavior okay I got
some problems with that but let's get
through all of them myth number two
there are no studies linking violent
video game play too serious aggression
fact high levels of violent video game
exposure have been linked to delinquency
fighting at school and during free play
periods and violent criminal behavior I
mean what else you going to do there in
free play periods and number three
unrealistic video game violence is
completely safe for adolescents and
older youths facts cartoonish and
fantasy violence is often perceived
incorrectly by parents and public policy
makers is safe however experimental
studies with college students have
consistently found increased aggression
after exposure to clearly unrealistic
and fantasy violent video games okay so
they're giving us a lot to work with
there so you know what I'm just going to
let you talk before I ask a question
thanks Dave yeah well I've covered this
a lot on my channel nerd alert it's one
of my most I want I don't want to say
pet because I hate it it's being made a
lot yeah there were a few problems I had
in those myths vs. fats first of all it
says aggressive behavior aggressive
isn't necessarily violent like Killy
with a gun yeah first of all another one
was there was a link to delinquency a
link to this kind of person but that
doesn't really a correlation is not a
causation so that it could be that kind
of person is already drawn to video
games and another thing who I'm getting
mad yeah bring it you want to break
something that would actually only prove
their point yeah no no um so video games
are brought up often as something like
it when there's a shooting oh he played
grand theft auto yeah it cost this
that's not really a fair thing to say
it's it's a it's a popular scapegoat
even our friend Diane Feinstein kind of
flipped on that
after i believe Sandy Hook she attempted
to get gun legislation in and it did not
work for various reasons as a whole
that's a whole other whole another story
but we're gonna stay on topic she kind
of changed ponies and then at one point
said oh well we have to be aware of
these violent video games that are
causing kids to do this she changed
ponies because she wanted her name on
the legislation against something with
Sandy Hook that's she was using it as
politicians so often do as a scapegoat a
crutch and it's frankly the the facts
don't support this yeah okay so I want
to get into some of the specifics that
Kim mentioned but let's go to the
scapegoating first because to me it just
seems like a giant scapegoat this is
just idiotic because I grew up playing
video games even grand theft auto III
never even played the game to accomplish
anything all I would do would be punched
people and throw people out of a car and
drive over people and you get to me you
get that aggression out and I never felt
violent after playing it uh I actually
I'm a v8 mushrooms because Mario did but
that's a whole other thing uh but but
really I mean do what what do you think
the good momoka portobello mushrooms ma
okay yeah what do you think uh yeah you
know I mean I think it totally causation
is not necessarily correlation what did
you say with statistics is very very
very good what was your free kind of
machination causation and correlation
are not the same thing yes it's not
something that caused something else
well it's just something a fact that's
there that also is has another fat
beside it right it's we're noting that
it's there we're not noting that one we
got the other yeah I mean I think that
if maybe if you're predisposed to
aggressive behavior you're interested in
theoretically in violent video games
because it speaks to your aggressiveness
yeah I will say this though for work we
do a lot of video game reviews we do a
lot of playthroughs there were two games
that I kind of mainlined last year that
was BioShock Infinite and also grand
theft auto 5 and it was like 15 our play
days of this just non-stop and anytime
you do anything for that amount of time
I mean it kind of screws up with your
brain like your body gets used to like
thinking in this this pattern and
you know go outside in la cienega and
think about how can I steal that car and
drive it into the faculty center blow it
up you know I mean you never really do
it right but it's like thought actually
did pop in your head any and maybe but
some really more of a my problem kind of
thing you know and it's really more
about me as a person but I wouldn't
necessarily attribute it to grand theft
auto but if you do anything I mean if
you watched if you if you watch house of
cards and you and you mainline that like
so many people did I was manipulating
everybody you know like they'll well now
they know yeah sorry but but yeah I was
just like you know I was I was like the
I'm actually gonna be the president
pretty soon spoiler alert sorry well you
know interestingly in house of cards
they did it more in season one that he
was playing video games to get out his
aggression then in season two he got it
out in other ways I suppose especially
in the first episode but yeah so this is
just purely scapegoat stuff I mean why
don't people ever talk about the good
parts of video games the eye hand
coordination and the fact that you might
be exercising some other aggressions and
getting them out normal sure there's
there's things such as the concept of
flow which is a psychological concept
I've talked about before it's something
where your your mind gets very you're
you're doing something that's very
challenging but also very rewarding to
you and it's this great reliever in your
psychological state you can get this
from playing Tetris but one thing I
wanted to talk about on the term back to
scapegoating yeah this is not the first
time this has ever happened of course
you can go call back to the comic code
authority of the 1950s and then it was
this government group censoring comics
and comments can only be approved by
them saying like oh they're they're
hurting our children they're making them
violent and delinquent with that rock
and roll those blue jeans right so it's
just the next extension of all really
extension it just keeps this will happen
again with whatever is after video games
are the next version of video games yeah
so I'm curious you guys that are in the
the gamer community what happen every
time there's a shooting and then some
idiot gets on TV and blames video games
without knowing anything what goes on in
the gamer community actually like on the
message board and on you know Xbox Live
and all that like our people are people
talking about it do they just ignore it
do they feel like they're being attacked
no I think unless you want to be
self-righteous about it and you want to
put it up for people to you know freak
out about that for the most part it's
ignored because I
think it's really taken very seriously I
mean video gamers really are more
interested in that was kind of cool
that's violence again video game video
gamers are more interested in you know
the imagination of a video game of the
world building of the kind of alternate
reality experience that you get from
doing something that's an active
intellectual experience a lot of times
in a lot of these games are super story
have a a lot of them are really
difficult from a coordination standpoint
and I think when you really when you
really are true gamer you get that it's
not about that but so far I you know it
looks like to a lot of us I think
Washington just being upset yeah kind of
disagree i don't think it's
self-righteous to stand up for yourself
and say that i'm not this is not what
causes me to feel this way and i think
that's a problem actually that gamers
kind of keep to themselves and don't say
don't stand up more for themselves and
let these figures bear down on them and
blame them for things sure and let me
I'll restate I mean it's self righteous
if you're going to be somebody who's
posting this story defending it saying
like you know you guys are the reason
that all these shootings are happening I
mean there's no that I don't think that
it's an active conversations being
really had and if you are going to bring
that up it's like you're probably just
trolling because you're looking for
somebody that you know something to
fight about and you know what gamers
don't have to agree on everything so I
think that is actually ok and I would be
remiss if we did something on video game
violence and school shootings and all
that and we didn't talk about the
prescription drug angle because that
seems like a far bigger problem than the
video games to me is that does that just
seemed pretty obvious to you guys
because that's what we always find out
too they don't always play video games
but ninety percent of the time I'm
willing to say they're on some sort of
prescription always stellar parenting I
play as well yes sometimes these games
are rated mature in their rate of mature
for a reason I'm not saying that causes
anything I am saying maybe you should be
aware of what your child is playing and
doing and watching yeah yeah I mean I
think that obviously mental illness is a
really big issue we see it everywhere
especially in Los Angeles unfortunately
and you know until we sort of address
that as the cause of the problem they
like the issues up here right the issue
the issue is from within and it's not
necessarily the external fault you know
I think that maybe there's triggers
things that make people go crazy and go
off the deep end so speak but but you
know it's it's until we turn the
conversation I feel like I'm a Hannity
but if you turn it until we turn the
conversation to sort of more about you
know just like what's going on and from
a mental standpoint than I think that
you can blame anything and you'll have
just exhaustive list of things to talk
about and for the record people Hannity
causes shootings not video games there
you go all right let's talk about
atheism a little bit we've covered in a
bunch on the show and I thought this was
really interesting a study called the
freethought report 2013 found out that
there are 13 countries around the world
where you can face execution under the
law for being an atheist we've got a
list of the countries Afghanistan Iran
malaysia maldives mauritania Nigeria
Pakistan Qatar Saudi Arabia Somalia
Sudan United Arab Emirates Yemen okay
and unfortunately none of those
countries surprise anyone i think that
knows anything about that part of the
world we did a story last week on the
seven countries in the world that you
can still be put to death for being gay
a bunch of them were on there so before
we get into the specifics about atheism
should anything that goes on in that
part of the world surprises how do we
drag them out of the Dark Ages and into
some sort of enlightenment that maybe
we're in here we had enlightenment
anymore we're past enlightenment now
we're in the we're on the other side of
enlightenment now but can we just get
them a little bit to come this way the
regimes in some of these countries are
not what we would call democratic even
though they might say over the
Democratic Republic so yeah oh god
Christine John Ellis it's a lot of
control I think that's that's part of it
and religion is a great way to
institutionalize control so that's what
i think is at work here at base yeah i'm
not surprised i'm also disappointed
though okay so the big thing on TV this
week was cosmos came back on sunday
night the Carl Sagan classic and uh
there was an interesting piece where
they they did some animation they gave
us some cartoons & Giordano give me his
last name Bruno where he was basically
condemned
to a life in jail because he kept
telling everyone that the universe is
infinitely bigger than we think it is
which is now something we know is
basically a scientific fact the you know
and they did this really interesting
thing with the arrow and if the arrow
goes through the universe and it ends
somewhere well then what's on the other
side of the end and that was sort of how
they visualized it for us these
countries haven't got out then here they
show basically how the church basically
destroyed this guy's life even though he
was saying like oh our God made this
huge universe our God did this for us he
was still acting in the confines of
religion yeah it just wasn't the right
way right so I think there's a great
parallel to what was going on then and
this is you know many hundred years ago
versus what's happening in these
countries now why is it that religious
why can't they make some sort of
reconciliation between belief and
science well I mean and it's not even
necessarily believe in science it's
their belief against all other beliefs I
mean they I mean allegedly would execute
bhai or Christians as well you know
which I think that the I think kind of
huffpo with the article at least that I
read about this sort of mrs. that a
little bit because you know maybe tough
phone and that's more interesting
obviously it's about education I guess
and it's about saying you know the
people who are are there if they have
the power to sort of understand freedom
from a religious standpoint they're
going to do what they what they have to
do to get that but unfortunately you
know that's not ever an easy safe
inexpensive or fast process yeah so
every week that we do some sort of
international story whether it's about
Syria Ukraine or something because I'm
an American I bring it back to what can
America's role be in this every time we
do something internationally everyone
hates us and if we don't do anything
people hate us too so if we're gonna be
hated either way is there anything we
can do to either to protect the safety
of these people or to push the regime's
to do more to help them or it's just is
it sort of a lost cause at this point
atheism is not mainstream in America too
I mean we kind of associate being
patriotic with being religious yeah I
don't think that's a fair equivocation
but that's sort of the mindset atheists
don't do that well in terms of
discrimination
in the United States either and it yes
and we were speaking about this earlier
religion or impose religion is a means
of keeping people from thinking on their
own and getting their their ideas past
what the state's ideas are so yes there
is a some sort of a relation there I
don't know that we're going to do
anything as a nation to help atheists
internationally at this point okay so
I'm gonna stick with America cuz I think
you make a good point it seems to me
that we have a huge percentage of people
that are sort of closeted atheists I
mean by some studies they say it's
something like twenty percent of the
United States now identifies with
atheism that that would be a huge
political movement why don't we see more
do they just not want to get mixed up in
politics because of the sort of
left-right nature you'll get shunned you
maybe can't gin up people's fears as
much I think it's definitely would be
one of the things you probably wouldn't
bring up at a cocktail party I guess
depending on where you are in the
country but it's not so mainstream that
it's like people if they are if they're
not atheists I think that they they
don't accept it in the same way that we
sort of allow exception for other sort
of minority view points or minorities I
think that the way that America could
help right is if we recognize a theism
as just another facet of religious
freedom right and so we say well our
more relativity allows us to see that as
as a problem because we think here like
everybody should be allowed to do what
they want to do and so if we're a lot
you know able to communicate communicate
that it doesn't have to be about atheism
everybody is helped you know and i think
that at the end of the day that's you
know that's that's better yeah i think
that's actually a really good point if
you frame it in a context that they can
sort of understand that it might
actually make some sense um do we need
more celebrities to be atheists I say
that only half-jokingly but if we had a
couple people you know Barney Frank the
congressman many you know for 30 years
out of Massachusetts he was openly gay
in the early 80s he didn't come out as
an atheist until about six months or a
year ago on real time with bill maher so
he was more comfortable saying I'm gay
which if you said that in the 80s that
certainly wasn't helping his political
career it's not really helping anyone's
political career now but he had to wait
till he retired to say he was an atheist
so does that just sort of say it all as
to where we're at in terms of well
they're definitely need to be strides
made there needs to be someone who's
ready to martyr himself or herself I
guess order a business people are going
to not accept it at first I mean dealing
even with members of my own family
they're horrified by the idea of atheism
and but they don't really seem to
understand what it means either I think
once we get more of that information out
there and more understanding I what do
you think the misconception is that
somehow you don't believe the only thing
like you're in Iowa don't care about
children and America it's it's just very
weird and oddly out blown yeah do you
think cosmos is going to actually help
in this regard so it's not talking about
atheism specifically at least not in the
one episode that's been out but sort of
just bringing science to a
understandable level giving us a little
bit of that I know that the Catholic
League was very upset with cosmos they
thought they were being attacked
basically just forgiving factual sure
evasion it happened right at the end of
the day it's a tough thing for religion
and science to co-exist together I think
throughout history it's all obviously
kind of always been this like play back
and forth between them and I think now
that the rapid advancements in
information and technology allow us to
sort of have more explainable answers to
things that we turn to religion to
explain as that occurs I think more
people will sort of be you know
especially of our generation are less
entranced by the idea of religion but it
depends on who you ask I mean you're you
sort of asked a question you know what
can we do to help you know the cause of
the atheists it's like if you're not an
atheist then like there is nothing you
can do and I mean I think that talking
about atheists as like an oppressed
people is is maybe a little bit absurd
you know because I think the whole idea
is the hands-off kind of thing was it's
like we should be free to do whatever we
want to do and if we really believe in
that if we as a country as is our
founding then let's all just do that and
right and I think I think a lot of
people I know in the YouTube comments
people are gonna be saying well even in
those countries you're free to believe
whatever you want
because the government can't get into
your brain but there's a difference
between you know privately believing
what you wanted still being able to
express yourself as a human being I
think we even Neil deGrasse Tyson he's
never come out and said I'm an atheist
he's I think he's veered away from that
and I think he's done that for a good
reason so you think he probably is it
all understanding bake for him I don't
know but it's possible right but but
he's never really said like I reject
religion entirely and it's all a sham
he's never said that very interesting
Neil deGrasse Tyson if you want to come
on the show and discuss I'd be happy to
have you and finally I thought this was
really interesting a study came out a
Pew study saying that Millennials are
becoming more and more unlike their
parents fifty percent of Millennials are
self-described political independence
twenty-seven percent said Democrat and
seventeen percent said Republican almost
two-thirds don't classify themselves as
a religious person and only one in for
Millennials is married almost half of
the baby boomers were married at this
age so the political end of that that
doesn't really surprise me in any way I
mean people are just so sick of politics
and now for all the other topics that
we've been talking about the show with
all the ways you can get information now
we're just endlessly bombarded with this
nonsense out of our political system so
that that shouldn't surprise us right I
was reading this article and I felt like
he did this because of me cuz i felt
like it described Liam you are Howell do
you um 20s twenties which qualifies as a
millennial I think yeah okay fair fair I
am above the Millennial age I will put
that out there yeah you're a millennial
i am i ashamed Julie you know I mean I
spent a lot of time with Millennials I
grew up with them I think that I think
that unfortunately a lot of the
hyperbole that we sort of exude with our
buzzfeed mentality and our kind of
lackadaisical attitudes it's not a
stereotype it's true I mean a lot of
people are very entitled and it's
obnoxious it's easier for people who
aren't entitled now because like there's
not as much competition
able to get married and no I'm just
talking abut Millennials as a whole
compared to our parents generation as
far as marriage goes it's really
marriage in a church right i mean
obviously a lot of my friends are
getting married now i mean even more
than I think that I would expect and
probably I mean being from Indiana more
than out here certainly but I will say
that if you've ever been to a wedding
you know that a wedding is about getting
drunk for the most part and it's a lot
more fun to be drunk in a lot less fun
rather to be drunk in a church than it
is to be drunk at a Shakey's Pizza
Parlor in irvine I'm just saying you
know I mean wow he really on
the sanctity of marriage I boy and
shakeys does anyone get married a
Shakey's i'm not sure but let's look at
a graph comparing the different
generations so the percent who consider
themselves politically independent and
you can see the way way higher
Millennials Generation X that is my
generation we're a little bit below the
Boomer is just a tiny bit below
Generation X which does surprise me and
thirty two percent of the Silent
Generation identify as political
independence and on the right side
percentage of adults in each generation
who are religiously unaffiliated and
again Millennials are the highest janx
boomer silent so that all sort of makes
sense is this just evolution of thought
in a free country that people will get
away from dogma we just did the story
about 13 countries where you can be put
to death for atheism so in a free
society you're going to stray away from
back Hannah stuff I think so because
just from my point of view I don't
affiliate myself with a political party
and I never have I if I get married I
don't know if I want it I don't actually
want to do it in a church and a lot of
it is wanting to not want rejecting
dogma and wanting to think on your own
and have your own thoughts like for
instance I voted for president obama in
2012 it's not I don't sit necessarily
agree with everything he does in fact I
openly disagree with a lot of things he
does but that just seemed like the
better alternative at the time I don't
want to necessarily abide by Democratic
Dogma or Presbyterian Dogma or anything
like that I want to be able to consider
these all by myself yeah so I don't want
to make this too much about politics but
as part of this that
the Republicans numbers really aren't
that different anymore and it's all
about big money in business and we know
all that so people vote for things that
they don't you know you're just most
people I think actually are voting for
the lesser of two evils yeah and you're
really not doing much yeah I I don't
know I mean I think like when I think
about when I went to high school and I
got edumacated it was with a bunch of
other Millennials and we really didn't
have a very robust sort of political
program you know I mean it was kind of
like I think a lot of people maybe don't
they just feel disingenuous
disenfranchised by the whole process and
especially with you know the way things
have been people's approval ratings from
Washington are so low we're less
interested in sort of the political or
the religious kind of fundamental
fundamentals yeah do you think when we
talk about these generational things and
they're really not quite generations
because the millennial generation right
now is 18 to 33 that's not quite a
generation of people but do you think
that that age range is too big because
if you're say 30 right now you have a
huge discrepancy in your life and you're
an adult in living a life hopefully with
a job and independently rather than an
eighteen-year-old it's a really big gap
well do you think it's more of an age
gap like you those 18 year olds will
eventually be similar to the 30 year
olds when they're at that point in their
lives or do you think they're actually
have a divide and thought ah well that's
a good right so I guess that well that's
the question do they suddenly shift out
and start thinking like the generations
we get older right so is also part of
this that people have more liberal views
when they're young and then suddenly
what wet what happens I never understand
you start paying money you start paying
to have you start paying more taxes than
you were before and especially if you're
self-employed you know you start
realizing how much of your money that
you've you you know put on the table it
gets taken away to pay for things that I
think that you maybe don't really feel
benefit you at least that I think
historically has been it obviously I
think we're probably a lot more socially
aware than then
we were in the past but you know the
other thing is really horrible for the
Republicans is like is the abortion and
the gay thing you know they just it just
for someone in my generation it's just
an immediate turn off I think I think no
you can't get past that even if you like
the the the economic policy of sort of
more limited government you just you
just can't get behind somebody who's so
you know yeah unsolvable to some some
people maybe us included that there
wouldn't be equal rights for gay people
that their abortions would be illegal
things like that and it just you can't
get around it right there's it's
unbreakable sort of being a big part of
that right so that being said 2016 when
the route you know we're gonna have two
wide open are you know I guess Hillary's
already been anointed Queen but we're
gonna have two races at least two
primary races is there going to be one
Republican that has the balls to say I'm
okay with k equality and I don't love
abortion but I don't want to make it
illegal well every one of those 12
dingbats that get on stage and say
something there has to be or they are I
don't know if they'll survive yeah and
the only one the only one off not so the
only one that they had in 2012 that sort
of did that was Jon Huntsman and he was
basically laughed out of the camp yeah
and unfortunately he also he was a
Mormon you know and you see how that
turned out right almost worked for Mitt
that's right it's right but still yeah
two of them yeah good at it is just
blasphemy um I think you know jeez if
somebody's able to communicate like why
you would be a Republican if you're not
a religious sort of zealot then I think
that's really powerful but I just don't
see it happening because a the name is
so bad it's like the other it's like BAM
are like drag it through the mud yeah
every single time and and you know I
think a lot of people's hearts in my
generation we're really libertarian you
know we like the idea of a freedom but
we just can't get behind the the
religion part alright well on that note
I hope we've given you a little
something to think about here i want to
thank Andy Reese Meyer Kim torture and
all you young Millennials out there I
know if you don't have to do one thing
it's click Subscribe which is right down
below
comment will we'll talk back to you let
us know what you think and we will do it
all again next week thanks for watching